on nous expliquait ce portrait
économique et budgétaire le ministre des
finances lui-même bel morneau qu'on
retrouve à ottawa merci d'être là
monsieur morte aux rues d'autres du coup
ça donne quand même le vertige le
déficit que vous avez dévoilé
aujourd'hui 343 milliards de dollars
comment on explique sa ce chiffre
colossal au canadien c'est c'est vrai
c'est une c'est une situation très
difficile
bien sûr c'est une chose qu'un autre
système économique mais la cause c'est
clair c'est le temps dani c'est la même
situation à trouver le monde
on a ou une fois le choix était à mon
avis très très facile on doit avoir un
niveau de support pour les canadiens et
les canadiennes à travers le pays et y
compris les québécoises et les québécois
parce que on est dans une situation très
difficile et on doit avoir une prendre
d'ici à la fin de la pandémie
et ça c'est une autre reproche ses 343
milliards monsieur mono c'est une photo
c'est une estimation aujourd'hui mais
vous avez dans votre document
aujourd'hui plusieurs scénarios reprise
plus lente même résurgence du virus donc
est ce que le déficit pourrait être
encore plus important dans l'avenir
ce que nous avons fait une impro très
économique et c'était important de de
dire ce qu'ils savent en ce moment mais
en même temps la situation est très
fluide donc on a expliqué notre
situation on a des prévisions qui sont
jusqu'à la fin mars 20 21 et à notre vie
ça c'est une possibilité mais nous
savons pas en ce moment le situation
dans la tombe dans l'hiver les choses
importantes pour nous est de travailler
en s'en va avec les gens à travers le
pays pour assurer que notre situation
économique est bon et ça c'est si
nécessaire de considérer comment nous
pouvons combattre le co 20 19
ça c'est la seule façon d'avoir une
économie en croissance
et ça c'est une autre dit oui et
justement si vous continuer de soutenir
l'économie venir en aide à des causes
des canadiens ce qui serait possible de
prolonger certains programmes d'aidé ce
que c'est votre intention
nous avons expliqué dans le document à
une continuation de la subvention
salariale avec avec une provision pour
ce programme important mais en même
temps nous savons que le pc us et ça
doit diminuer et en même temps pour
notre système d'assurance emploi va doit
commencer recommencer donc les trois
programmes 1 doivent travailler ensemble
et ça c'est ça c'est une autre approche
et on a on a dans nos chiffres le
continuation de souvent sociale réelle
pour assurer qu'on va voir les emplois
on devrait avoir une réponse sécuritaire
de notre économie à les choses doit
travailler ensemble ouais tout le monde
s'entend il fallait faire quelque chose
pour venir en aide aux canadiens pour
relancer l'économie mais ça fait le
gouvernement s'endette plus de mille
milliards de dollars de dette est ce que
c'est raisonnable est ce qu'on peut se
le permettre c'est c'est clair qu'il ya
une choc ça c'est ça c'est ça c'est
notre situation le bon nouvèl s'il a des
bonnes nouvelles et que le coût de la
dette
en ce moment est de plus bas dans
l'histoire ça veut dire que aujourd'hui
on a un coût de dettes c'est une portion
de pib mais il y a dans les années 90
c'était 6 % de pib
donc il en grand changement c'est une
meilleure situation on doit gérer notre
dette et et on est en train de
considérer comment on pourrait avoir la
dette pour le long terme ça va être plus
sécure pour nous mais bien sûr nous
devons considérer comment nous pouvons
voir le niveau de croissance pour
assurer qu'on a les emplois on allait
les opportunités dans l'avenir et de
cette façon on va avoir une économie qui
use est possible de diminuer notre
niveau 2 de déficit par rapport à notre
pays parce que la dette c'est une
préoccupation les taux d'intérêt sont
faibles maintenant ne le seront
peut-être pas toujours est ce que les
générations futures vont finir par payer
pour cette crise là le raison que nous
nous sommes en train de dassier d'avoir
une approche de gérer le dette et parce
que nous savons que maintenant on peut
considérer les dettes dix en 30 ans et
ça va diminuer le risque d'une
changement dans le cou de dettes mais
bien sûr c'est clair ils en sont où on
doit conserver l'avenir notre proche
faire des investissements dans notre
économie pour avoir un niveau de
croissance
et ça c'est ça c'est la prochain un
autre vie qui qui est bon mais justement
vous parlez d'investir dans l'économie
stimuler la reprise
il n'y a pas beaucoup de pistes d'un 10
de votre stratégie dans le document
aujourd'hui monsieur morneau nous
nous sommes dans une situation nous
savons où nous sommes aujourd'hui
ça veut dire que c'est le temps pour la
réunion sécuritaire
donc on a maintenant une négociation
avec les provinces pour avoir leurs
raisons sécuritaires et ça c'est ce
qu'on doit faire
pendant les prochaines mois et de cette
façon avec ça et une essaie d'assurer
que le croc river c est moins important
on peut avoir une meilleure situation
dont la tombe donc chaque chaque temps
on va être clair ou le sens mais
vraiment c'est difficile à dire ce qu'on
doit faire dans l'anthologie d'heure la
consommation connaît en ce moment mais
tous les gouvernements du monde monsieur
mort non se tourne c'est une solution
classique vers les infrastructures par
exemple pour relancer l'économie ce que
ça pourrait être parmi les stratégies de
votre gouvernement
je dois dire que notre situation avec le
pain de mie est une plus différents que
les récessions avant ça veut dire que on
a eu une diminuation du demande à cause
d'eux le clôture de l'économie donc ça
c'est une situation très difficile
différents qu'avant donc si on peut
augmenter le niveau de demande grecque
avec par exemple souvent sociale réelle
nous pensons qu'on peut avoir une
relance de l'économie et après ça on
doit dire ce qu'on doit faire
bien sûr il faut que chaque joueur est
une chose qui qui peut être important
mais quand nous sommes dans une
situation avec leur élan sécuritaire on
doit considérer ce qu'on doit faire avec
une prochaine attaque il ya énormément
d'incertitudes vous le répéter et c'est
vrai est ce qu'on a comme marge de
manoeuvre s'il devait y avoir une
deuxième vague est ce qu on a un coussin
qu'est ce qu'on a prévu
c'est clair que
nous étions dans une bonne situation à
fiscale avant avant la crise ça c'était
bon après tout les investissements nous
sans nous continuons d'être le plus bas
entre l'épée g7 au niveau de dakar pour
un autre économie donc ça c'est ça
continue d'être une bonne position
bien sûr nous devons avoir l'économie
après la crise donc ça c'est les choses
le plus important on devait on doit
avoir des investissements pour les
emplois donc on doit être prudent mais
on doit considérer notre goût et ça
c'est une beau d'avoir les opportunités
pour pour lesquelles aider les canadiens
à prix moyen en termine à monsieur
morneau à quel moment être qu'on peut
prévoir le dépôt d'un vrai budget on a
expliqué dans notre document aujourd'hui
qu'on va avoir quelque chose dans le
tome 1 avec avec plus d'une formation au
niveau de notre situation économique
si c'est une budget une mise à jour
économique
on veut avoir plus à dire dans quelques
mois on va suivre ça de très près merci
beaucoup monsieur morneau mais bon c